also happening today downtown Summerlin
is celebrating Earth Day a day early and
kicking it off today with a farmer's
market it's put on by our local students
here selling food grown at their own
School Gardens it is to promote healthy
decisions and teach students the value
of gardening proceeds from the market
will benefit gardening programs at more
than 60 Local Schools this is really fun
if you've never been you should go the
kids will be there from 9 30 this
morning until 1 in the afternoon selling
their carrots and their zucchinis and
their squash and all the other good
foods that they grow and so proudly
bring and put on the tables for sale
John